.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Er würde sich unsterblich machen,
hätte seine Erfindung Erfolg.
Martin Bachmann forscht
an einem Impfstoff gegen Corona.
Sie haben den Stoff an sich
schon getestet.- Ja, schon lange.
Er sorgt als Krisenchef
immer wieder für Aufsehen.
Martin Bühler gilt als kreativer Mann
im Kampf gegen das Virus.
Wir müssen einen anderen Weg finden,
als den Menschen
das Leben zu verbieten.
In dieser Reportage
begleiten wir zwei Männer
über ein Jahr lang
durch die Corona-Krise.
Beide haben unterschiedliche
Aufgaben, aber dasselbe Ziel.
Im Februar 2020
treibt Corona die Welt vor sich her.
Martin Bühler,
Leiter des Amtes für Militär
und Zivilschutz im Kanton Graubünden,
ist mehr gefordert denn je.
Dank eines Pandemieplanes
sind die Bündner gut vorbereitet -
mit 500'000 Schutzmasken.
Hier sehen wir
die eingelagerten Schutzmasken.
Das sind alles
medizinische Einwegmasken.
Das Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz
hat uns die Möglichkeit gegeben,
für Notfälle und hohe Priorisierung
Masken mit noch höherer Qualität
zu bestellen.
Wir haben sofort Gebrauch
von der Möglichkeit gemacht.
Die sind angekommen.
Das sind die, oder?- Genau.
Am Donnerstag, 27. Februar, hat das
Virus den Kanton Graubünden erreicht.
Der engste Kreis des Krisenstabes
trifft sich zu einer
eilends einberufenen Sitzung.
Wie du mitgekriegt hast, haben wir
schon zwei bestätigte Fälle -
im Oberengadin und in St. Moritz.
- Ja.
Im Verlauf des Tages
machen wir eine Neubeurteilung.
Dann schauen wir, was weiter läuft.
V.a. steht noch offen -
das ist etwas Grosses -,
was mit dem Engadiner Skimarathon
in einer Woche passiert.
Wir haben aber
noch nichts entschieden.
Ich glaube,
es versteht schlussendlich niemand,
wenn wir jetzt nicht absagen.
Was ist denn die Konsequenz?
Sagen wir jetzt ab?
Es bringt nichts, jetzt zu zögern.
Es ist in diesem Fall mehr klar,
als nicht klar.
Es gibt eine Zunahme
und wir haben bestätigte Fälle.
Die Veranstaltung an sich
ist risikobehaftet.
Ist das gut? Also, gut ist es nicht,
aber machen wir es so?
Es ist die richtige Entscheidung.
- Gut.
Der Engadiner Skimarathon ist der
erste grosse Anlass in der Schweiz,
der abgesagt wird.
Tags darauf.
Bundesrat Alain Berset
tritt vor die Medien.
29 Menschen
haben sich laut BAG schweizweit
mit dem Coronavirus angesteckt.
Deswegen haben wir in der Sitzung
von heute Morgen entschieden,
dass die Situation in der Schweiz
als besondere Lage einzustufen ist -
gemäss Epidemiengesetz, Artikel 6.
Wir haben auch entschieden,
dass Grossveranstaltungen
mit mehr als 1'000 Personen
zu verbieten sind.
Diese Verordnung ist seit
heute Morgen um 10 Uhr in Kraft.
Martin Bachmann
auf dem Weg zur Arbeit.
Der Professor
arbeitet im Inselspital Bern.
Dort leitet der 52-Jährige
die Abteilung Immunologie.
Unter Bachmanns Leitung forscht
sein Team seit Ausbruch der Pandemie
an einem Corona-Impfstoff.
Am Anfang seiner Forschungen
konzentrierte er sich auf das Virus,
welches den Menschen krank macht.
Angeblich
wendet der Erreger einen Trick an:
Wir glauben zu wissen,
was der Trick ist.
Darum können wir unseren Impfstoff
so bauen,
dass das nicht passiert und man
gute, langlebige Antikörper kriegt.
Hier sehen Sie das Virus,
Das SARS-CoV-2.
Sie sehen diese Spikes hier.
Was ist ein Spike?
- Etwas wie ein ...
Eben das hier. Etwas, das rausragt.
- Ein Zapfen?
Genau.
Das Gelbe hier
ist quasi seine Achillesferse.
Das ist der Teil hier.
- Was haben Sie gemacht?
Das sehen wir auf dem nächsten Bild.
Was wir gemacht haben, ist:
Wir haben die heikle bzw. empfind-
liche Stelle des Virus genommen
und sie auf einen anderen Träger
transplantiert.
Der Träger
heisst virusartiges Partikel.
Der kommt
von einem speziellen Pflanzenvirus.
Das machen wir
aber auch in Bakterien so.
Der abgeänderte Pflanzenpartikel
ist dann der eigentliche Impfstoff.
Wann denken Sie,
wird Ihr Impfstoff zugelassen?
Frühestens in einem Jahr.
Allerfrühestens.
Aber dafür
brauchen wir auch einen Partner.
Wir können das nicht alleine
stemmen. Das ist viel zu teuer.
In Bachmanns Labor arbeiten
rund 20 Forscherinnen und Forscher.
Dr. Mona Mohsen ist Biomedizinerin -
und zudem die Ehefrau
des Immunologen.
Wie ist es für Sie,
Privatleben und Arbeit zu teilen?
Manchmal ist es gut,
manchmal weniger,
v.a., wenn etwas nicht funktioniert
und er mir die Schuld gibt.
Aber oft ist es sehr schön.
Er ist mein Wikipedia.
Wenn ich eine Information brauche,
google ich Martins Hirn
und er beantwortet meine Frage.
Mona Mohsen ist normalerweise in der
Malaria- und Krebsforschung aktiv.
Im Augenblick konzentriert sie sich
auf die Entwicklung
des Corona-Impfstoffes.
In kleinen Mengen lässt sich
das Serum bereits herstellen.
Noch wird es nicht an Menschen,
sondern an Mäusen getestet.
Bei diesem Standardtest erkennt man,
ob sich Antikörper bilden.
Die Resultate sind vielversprechend.
Die Entwicklung
des COVID-19-Impfstoffes
ist ein Kampf gegen die Zeit.
Bachmanns kleines Forscherteam hat
grosse, internationale Konkurrenz.
Am Anfang der Krise ist
bei Martin Bühler noch vieles unklar.
So gibt es beispielsweise
keine gemeinsame Kommunikationsstelle
für alle Departemente.
Der Krisenchef will das ändern.
Doch nicht alle Kaderleute
sind darauf vorbereitet.
Sie haben Mühe,
Kompetenzen abzugeben.
Es ist wichtig, dass die Leute
Antworten auf ihre Fragen bekommen,
ohne suchen zu müssen.
Das ist das Ziel des Ganzen.
Es geht etwas darum,
die Dinge zu strukturieren
und u.a. auch die Kommunikation.
Wir möchten, dass ab Montag
eine Kommunikationsstelle live geht.
Zuerst: Wo ist das Problem
und was wollen wir erreichen?
Das haben wir rausgespürt,
aber noch nicht hundertprozentig.
Ich kann dir den Ablauf
nicht vorbeten.
Es braucht einen offenen Geist,
der sagt,
dass es Dinge hat, die klar sind,
und solche, die unklar sind.
Wir müssen in
einer unklaren Situation versuchen,
ein möglichst synchronisiertes
System zu bauen.
Aber du sagst ehrlich,
dass wir es nicht wissen
und wir das aufbauen würden.
Ich kam
mit einer anderen Erwartung rein.
Also Erwartung ...
Ich dachte, es sei etwas anders.
Aber das ist gut zu wissen.
Man gibt als Dienststellenleiter,
Departement oder Regierungsrat
einen Teil der Führungsverantwortung
ab.
Nach zwei Wochen
habe ich genug davon,
mit einem Fünfer- oder Siebener-Team
zu arbeiten.
Ich will, dass alle Departemente
und hochangesiedelten Stellen
die Last mittragen.
Mein Angebot ist,
dass jemand aus dem DVS
am Montag hier ist und in
der ersten Phase beim Aufbau hilft,
damit die verschiedenen Bedürfnisse
abgebildet werden.
Gut.
Vielen Dank.
Wir könnten weitermachen.
- Nein, jetzt hören wir auf
und gehen essen.
Vielen Dank, wirklich. Cool.
50 Menschen starben bisher in der
Schweiz im Zusammenhang mit Corona.
Der Bundesrat
reagiert auf die ernste Lage.
Der Bundesrat hat heute entschieden,
die Situation als
ausserordentliche Lage zu erklären.
Die Regelung gilt ab Mitternacht
und dauert vorerst bis am 19. April.
Damit haben wir in der ganzen
Schweiz einheitliche Regeln.
Alle Läden, Restaurants, Schulen
sowie Unterhaltungs- und
Freizeitbetriebe werden geschlossen.
Jetzt muss ein Ruck
durch unser Land gehen.
Martin Bühler ist verheiratet
und Vater von drei Kindern.
Seit Anfang März lebt der 44-Jährige
allein in einer Zivilschutzanlage.
Das ist jetzt ...
... das Studio.
Wir haben uns dazu entschieden,
dass ich hierherkomme,
weil ich viel unterwegs bin
und so sicher sein kann, dass ich
meine Familie nicht anstecke.
Meine Frau arbeitet.
Sie kümmert sich jetzt gleichzeitig
um die Kinder.
Wir müssen einfach sichergehen,
dass es klappt.
Ich wollte Krafttraining machen
und habe die Hanteln mitgenommen.
Das Training war, sie von Fideris
hierherzufahren und hinaufzutragen.
Seither haben sie Ruhe und ich auch.
Und persönliche Dinge,
was die Familie angeht und so?
Ich habe Zeichnungen
von meinen Töchtern erhalten.
Was schreiben sie
auf den Zeichnungen?
"Lieber Papa,
ich vermisse dich und hoffe,
dass das Coronavirus bald wieder
weg ist und du zurückkommen kannst."
"Ich habe dich
sehr, sehr, sehr gern. Deine Maria."
Ich glaube, das ist sie.
Ende März 2020.
Der Bundesrat hat mittlerweile
die grösste Mobilmachung seit
dem zweiten Weltkrieg ausgerufen.
Martin Bühler fährt
zu einem Treffen mit Offizieren.
Der Krisenchef will erfahren,
wo er die Soldaten
im Bündnerland einsetzen kann.
Zur Armee hat er eine enge Beziehung.
Bühler
ist Oberstleutnant im Generalstab
des Kommandos für Spezialkräfte.
Er studierte Politikwissenschaft,
Staats- und Völkerrecht.
Grüezi miteinander.
Hallo, Martin Bühler.
Es würde mich interessieren,
was ihr eigentlich
als euer Leistungsprofil seht.
Was macht ihr
und was macht ihr v.a. nicht?
Da haben wir mal den Spitsoldaten.
Den Spitalsoldaten.
Der Spitalsoldat ist
dafür ausgebildet, die Grundpflege
von Patienten in stabilen
Situationen sicherzustellen.
Jawohl.
Dann haben wir unsere Transportzüge
mit Patiententransporten.
Damit können wir selbstständig
stabile Patienten transportieren.
Wir können Fahrer, Beifahrer plus
ein oder zwei Begleiter stellen.
Sagen Sie das noch mal!
Könnten wir zum Du wechseln?
Ich bin Martin, wenn das okay ist.
- Mhm.
Ist das gut?
- Tipptopp.- Gut.
Wir haben Fahrer plus Beifahrer
und ein bis zwei Begleitpersonen.
Und unsere Leute
können im Schichtbetrieb arbeiten.
Bühler
kann nun mit dem Leistungskatalog
die Soldaten
gezielt in den Spitälern einsetzen.
Martin Bachmann
besucht in Zürich einen Kollegen,
der an der Entwicklung
des Impfstoffes beteiligt ist.
Es gibt ein Problem zu besprechen,
welches die Zulassung des Impfstoffes
betrifft.
Bachmann
möchte für Studien an Testpersonen
den Impfstoff
in Literflaschen abfüllen.
Doch die Behörden verlangen,
dass das Serum
in Einzeldosen verabreicht wird.
Darüber ärgert sich Thomas Kündig,
Leiter Dermatologie
am Universitätsspital Zürich.
Es ist einfach ein Witz,
dass wir fürs Abfüllen
zwei Monate oder so verlieren.
- Es kostet 1,5 Mio. Fr.
Das ist einfach ein Witz.
Für die Studie brauchen wir ...
Man kann in einer Flasche
zehn Impfstoffdosen haben
und diese von Hand aufziehen.
- Kein Problem.
Sie kommen hierher und haben
eine Literflasche mit Impfstoff.
Und aus dem Liter
soll man dann 1'000 ...
... Leute impfen oder so.
Aber jetzt verlangt Swissmedic,
dass wir das quasi
in einzelne Fläschchen abfüllen.
Dieses Abfüllen
ist jetzt ein riesiges Thema.
Es kostet über 1 Mio. Fr.
Diese Kosten sind ja völlig absurd.
Wenigstens
weiss Martin Bachmann inzwischen,
dass sein Impfstoff
am Menschen wirkt.
Er hat ihn nämlich
an sich selbst ausprobiert.
Bildeten sich bei Ihnen Antikörper?
- Ja, bei mir schon.
Ich bin aber nur eine Person.
Wir prüften noch eine zweite.
Man muss das aber
in einem grösseren Rahmen machen.
Wie finden Sie es, dass er
sich das selber gespritzt hat?
Ich ... Ich ... äh ...
... möchte das aus klinisch-regula-
torischer Sicht nicht kommentieren.
Ich würde niemandem
einen Impfstoff spritzen,
den ich entwickelt habe,
ohne zuerst bei mir zu schauen,
ob er nützt
oder keine Nebenwirkungen hat.
Ich habe damit
aus persönlicher Sicht kein Problem.
Aber ich weiss, dass die regula-
torische Sicht eine andere ist.
Aber ich finde es
aus ethischer Sicht nicht falsch.
Vier Wochen stand die Schweiz still.
Bisher starben laut Angaben des BAG
über 1'100 Menschen
im Zusammenhang mit Corona.
Aber es gibt auch gute Nachrichten.
Die Ausbreitung des Coronavirus
wurde gebremst
und unsere Spitäler
sind zurzeit nicht überlastet.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Ihr folgt gleich
eine weitere gute Nachricht:
Nun können wir
erste Lockerungen vorsehen.
Nach Ende des Lockdowns
ist Martin Bühler
wieder zu seiner Ehefrau Sandra
und den drei Kindern zurückgekehrt.
Diese sind gerade in der Schule.
Viel Zeit füreinander hat das Ehepaar
aber noch immer nicht.
Sandra Bühler ist Dozentin
für Architektur und Siedlungsplanung
an der Fachhochschule Graubünden.
Sie unterrichtet ihre Studenten
nur noch online.
Nicht nur die Studenten
finden es interessant,
wenn der Dozent vor Ort ist,
sondern für uns als Dozenten
ist es sehr, sehr wichtig,
die Studenten
wirklich physisch vor Ort zu haben
und mit ihnen
Dinge erarbeiten zu können.
Das ist viel spannender
und macht auch viel mehr Spass.
Seine Frau fand es gut,
dass er während der ersten Monate
der Corona-Krise nicht daheim wohnte.
Er habe viel Nervosität in die
Familie gebracht, sagt Sandra Bühler.
Nervosität inwiefern?
Durch die ständigen Telefonate
und die ständige Erreichbarkeit.
Auch an den Wochenenden
und am Abend.
Und ... ähm ... ja ...
Es war dann einfacher,
als er ... ähm ...
... dann auf den Meiersboden ging,
um zu telefonieren.
Auch jetzt noch
ist es eigentlich so ...
... dass es je nach Wochenverlauf
einfacher ist, wenn ich wegbleibe.
Es kommen doch noch fast jeden Abend
Telefonate rein.
Darum.
An Wochenenden nimmt sich Martin
Bachmann fast immer eine Auszeit.
Im Kreis der Familie kann sich
der Immunologe gut entspannen.
Mit dabei sind jeweils auch seine
beiden inzwischen erwachsenen Kinder.
Und auch die Eltern des Immunologen
sind häufig zu Besuch.
Ihr Sohn sei als Kind ein Schlitzohr
gewesen, sagt die Mutter.
Wenn man ihm sagte,
er solle etwas machen,
sagte er immer, er würde es machen,
aber er machte es nicht.
Das ging aber wunderbar.
Der andere Sohn sagte immer,
er mache es nicht
und dann gab es Streit.
Er war immer gut.
Er konnte sich immer sehr gut
irgendwie durchwursteln.
Schon als Bub habe Martin einen
ausgeprägten Forscherdrang gezeigt.
So sei er auf Spaziergängen bei
jedem Schachtdeckel stehen geblieben.
Offenbar
war es seine Lieblingsbeschäftigung,
Steine
in die Schächte runterzuwerfen ...
... und zu warten,
bis es unten plätscherte.
Dann überlegte er sich,
wie tief der Schacht wohl ist.
Er katalogisierte die Schächte dann
nach deren Tiefen.
Je nach Echo, das es unten gab.
Die Familie
ist stolz auf den 52-Jährigen,
der es vom Dolendeckel-Forscher
bis zum Professor gebracht hat.
Ich habe sehr viel Respekt davor,
was er macht.
Ich weiss auch, dass er
auf seinem Gebiet extrem gut ist.
Aber wenn wir am Sonntag hier sind,
reden wir vielleicht die erste
halbe Stunde über seine Arbeit
und danach ist er nur noch ...
... lustig, wie er sonst immer ist.
Wir sehen uns viele doofe Filme an.
Man merkt nicht viel
von seiner Arbeit.
Im Inselspital Bern
hängen im Büro des Immunologen
etliche Ehrungen und Auszeichnungen.
Das ist ein Brief aus China,
der sagt,
dass ich jetzt Gastprofessor
an einer Universität in China bin.
Das sind Titelseiten von Journalen,
die unsere Figuren ausgewählt haben,
um auf der Titelseite zu erscheinen.
Das ist noch eine alte Seite
eines bekannten Journals:
"Journal of Experimental Medicine".
Sie sind ja ein mehrfach
ausgezeichneter Wissenschaftler.
Ja.
- Schmeichelt das?
Das ist auch einer:
Swiss Technology Award. Ja, schon.
Sie haben schon verschiedenste
Forschungen betrieben -
gegen Krebs, Alzheimer und Diabetes.
Kritische Stimmen sagen,
er habe bis jetzt noch nirgends
den Durchbruch richtig geschafft,
aber er mache grosse Versprechungen.
Das ist ein komischer Vorwurf.
Wir haben es einfach versucht.
Zeigen Sie mir jemand anderen,
der zehn Impfstoffe entwickelt hat,
ohne der Geschäftsführer
von Novartis zu sein.
Wir waren ja nie irgendwie ...
Es waren immer gute Ideen
und z.T. haben sie funktioniert.
Bei was denn?- Der gegen Diabetes
hat funktioniert.
Schlussendlich
ging der Firma einfach das Geld aus.
Darum
mussten wir vieles einstampfen.
Wir haben auch andere Impf...
Das ist auch alles sehr kompliziert.
Sie können auf Hunderte Arten
vom Weg abkommen.
Sehen Sie sich Novartis an!
Wie viele Produkte entwickelt
Novartis pro Jahr im eigenen Haus
mit einem 5-Mrd.-Budget?
15 Mio. Fr.
stehen Bachmann und seinem Team
für die Entwicklung
des Corona-Impfstoffes zur Verfügung.
Nebst einem Investor
ist auch eine Stiftung
an der Finanzierung beteiligt.
Um den Impfstoff
auf den Markt zu bringen,
brauche er noch viel mehr Geld,
sagt der Immunologe.
Er hofft, dass das Bundesamt für Ge-
sundheit ihn finanziell unterstützt.
Im Sommer 2020 muss Bachmann
einen herben Rückschlag verdauen.
Das BAG beteiligt sich nicht
an der Finanzierung
seiner Impfstoffforschung.
Sie sagten, dass sie
nur in Impfstoffe investieren,
die klar zugelassen sind.
Es sei nicht die Aufgabe des BAG,
Impfstoffforschung und -entwicklung
zu unterstützen.
Das BAG
nimmt nur schriftlich Stellung:
Sie haben erst drei Tage vorher er-
fahren, dass das BAG nicht mitmacht?
Die ganzen Verträge
waren ausgearbeitet.
Wir mussten auch Geld für Anwälte
ausgeben.
Es war sehr weit fortgeschritten und
dann kam aus dem Nichts ein Nein.
In der Schweiz
starben bisher 1'900 Menschen,
die sich mit Corona
angesteckt hatten.
Die Fallzahlen sind wieder gestiegen.
Der Bundesrat verschärft die Lage.
Die zweite Welle ist da
und kommt eher früher und stärker,
als wir gedacht hatten.
Ab sofort gilt die Maskenpflicht.
Anfang Winter
ist Krisenchef Martin Bühler -
wie viele andere auch - corona-müde.
Der Bundesrat
hat die Discos bereits geschlossen.
Den Gastronomiebetrieben, Sport- und
Kultureinrichtungen droht dasselbe.
Für mich persönlich
ist es frustrierend zu sehen,
dass wir auch nach
einem Dreivierteljahr mit dem Virus
vorwiegend versuchen, das Virus
über Beschränkungen zu bekämpfen.
Wir müssen im Umgang mit dem Virus
einen anderen Weg finden,
als den Leuten
das Leben zu verbieten.
Bühler hat bereits
einen anderen Plan:
Er will, dass sich möglichst
viele Menschen testen lassen.
Es gelang ihm,
ein Pilotprojekt zu organisieren.
Grossrätinnen und Grossräte
des Kantons Graubünden
lassen sich an diesem Tag testen.
Grüezi miteinander.
- Hei, tschau.- Hoi.
Geht es dir gut?
- Ja, schon negativ getestet.
Sehr gut.
Fast alle der 120 Mitglieder des
Grossrates machen bei der Aktion mit.
Je mehr Leute sich testen lassen
und sich dann in Isolation begeben
desto mehr asymptomatische Leute
finden wir
und desto weniger
können sie das Virus weitergeben.
Und wenn es viele sind, hilft das
mehr, als wenn es wenige sind.
Chef, alles klar?
- Ja, ja. Hoi.
Hast du alle im Griff?
- Wurdest du schon getestet?
Gerade jetzt.
- Gut.
Ich bin gespannt.
- Sehr gut.
Bist du jetzt Vollgas an den Tests?
Ja, wir müssen schauen,
was noch nicht funktioniert.
Stark.
- Das verbessern wir dann.
Kurz danach erfährt es Grossrat
Christof Kuoni per SMS: positiv.
Scheisse!
Ich nehme etwas Abstand von dir.
- Ist gut.
Er ist der einzig positiv getestete
Grossrat an diesem Tag.
Ich begrüsse ganz herzlich
Professor Martin Bachmann.
Er wird heute Abend zu uns sprechen.
Seien Sie ganz herzlich willkommen,
wir freuen uns, dass Sie hier sind.
Vor der Naturwissenschaftlichen
Gesellschaft in Winterthur
spricht Martin Bachmann
an einem Abend im November 2020
über seinen Impfstoff.
Fast nebenbei
erzählt er dann den Anwesenden
von einem weiteren Rückschlag.
Kann man mit dieser Methodik
Hunderte Millionen Impfdosen
in kurzer Zeit herstellen?
Die Antwort ist Nein.
Chancenlos.
In grossen Mengen lässt sich
sein Serum also nicht herstellen.
Gleichzeitig steht die Zulassung
von anderen Impfstoffen kurz bevor.
Bachmann versuchte,
mit der Konkurrenz mitzuhalten,
indem er seine Entwicklung
neu designte.
Ja, es sieht im Moment
nicht so gut aus.
Wir hatten einen Rückschlag
in der Produktion.
Wir mussten die ganze Produktion
verschieben.
Wir konnten nicht die grossen Mengen
herstellen, die wir wollten.
Es wurde jetzt
auf nächstes Jahr verschoben.
Was heisst das?
- Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Wir müssen schauen, wie man
die Produktion so gestalten kann,
dass wir jene Ausbeute kriegen,
die wir wollen.
Es ist eigentlich eine Enttäuschung.
Es war ein ehrgeiziger Fahrplan.
Der Impfstoff sollte schon da sein.
- Ja ...
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wir wollten ihn im November haben.
Das haben wir um Monate verpasst.
Das ist schon so, ja.
Ende Dezember 2020.
Der erste Mensch
wird in der Schweiz geimpft.
Martin Bühler Anfang Februar 2021.
Die Schweiz
steckt erneut im Lockdown.
Inzwischen
wird in der ganzen Schweiz geimpft.
Im Bündnerland
finden zudem auch Massentests statt.
Viele Gemeinden
beteiligen sich an der Aktion.
Herzlichen Dank an alle
für die Unterstützung!
Es ist wirklich schön,
wie das alles geklappt hat.
Vielen Dank!
Auch dafür,
dass ihr diesen schönen Sonntag
in diesem zwar schönen Raum
aber nicht an der Sonne verbringt.
Der Kanton finanziert die Tests
mit einem Betrag von 11 Mio. Fr.
Jede dritte Person macht mit.
Mit Erfolg:
Die Fallzahlen haben sich halbiert.
Schweizweit hat Graubünden
eine der tiefsten Ansteckungsraten.
Während Gratistests im Bündnerland
bereits selbstverständlich sind,
wartet der Bund noch zu.
Der Krisenchef will sein Konzept
Experten vorstellen.
Mit dabei ist auch ein Vertreter
des Bundesamtes für Gesundheit.
Wir beobachten das
sehr interessiert.
Wir hoffen, dass wir möglichst
gute Zahlen daraus ziehen können,
damit klar wird,
ob eine Möglichkeit besteht,
das als weitere Massnahme
einzuführen.
Beim eigentlichen Gespräch
sind Kameras nicht erlaubt.
Der Austausch
hat das BAG aber beeindruckt,
wie sich später noch zeigen wird.
Auch die Betriebe
sollen beim Testen mitmachen,
wünscht sich der Bündner Krisenchef.
Grüezi.
Einer der Ersten,
den Bühler ins Boot holen konnte,
war Schreiner Andres Walli
aus Küblis.
Das ist ein britisches Plakat
aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Das wäre aufgehängt worden, wenn ...
... die Invasion in Grossbritannien
stattgefunden hätte.
Dann hätte die britische Regierung
das aufgehängt:
"Keep calm and carry on".
Dieser Spruch gefällt mir.
Man muss die Situation nicht mit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg vergleichen,
Entschuldigung,
aber es geht auch darum,
ruhig zu bleiben und weiterzumachen.
Wir sind auch froh,
dass wir weitermachen können.
Es ist relativ einfach -
nach den Merkblättern des Kantons.
Hier kann man Tests rausnehmen.
Jeder Mitarbeiter
kann sich bedienen.
Es heisst ja, man soll es morgens
vor dem Zähneputzen machen.
Sie können den Test zu Hause machen
und ihn dort wieder reinlegen.
Das ist ...
... der "Bring"-Ort.
Dann gehen wir meistens so um 9 Uhr,
9.30 Uhr nach Schiers
und geben die Tests dort ab.
Das klappt sehr gut -
auch mit der Geschwindigkeit
der Auswertung.
Auch für Unternehmen
sind die Tests gratis,
vorfinanziert durch den Kanton.
1'800 Betriebe und 6'000 Einzelfirmen
machen in Graubünden mit.
Mehr als 9'700 Menschen starben
bisher im Zusammenhang mit Corona.
Um die Pandemie
besser in den Griff zu bekommen,
übernimmt nun auch der Bund
das Konzept der Bündner:
Gratistests für alle.
Der Kanton Graubünden
hat eine Vorreiterrolle eingenommen.
Ich kann mich gut daran erinnern,
dass Graubünden
am Anfang damit beginnen wollte.
Wir waren sehr interessiert daran,
das zu beobachten -
entschuldigen Sie das Wort.
Wir haben das beobachtet
und sind zum Schluss gekommen,
dass das eine gute Sache ist.
Wir haben die mögliche Entwicklung
gesehen.
Ja, Graubünden
hat eine Vorreiterrolle eingenommen.
Wir sehen ganz genau, dass
diese Massentests helfen können.
Bis der Bund
vom Bündner Programm überzeugt war,
dauerte es vier Monate.
Wertvolle Zeit ging so verloren.
Für mich ist es eindrücklich, wie
lange man z.T. für etwas braucht.
Ich möchte an unserem Beispiel
zeigen,
warum ich es wichtig finde,
dass man in einer so ausser-
ordentlichen Situation bereit ist,
gewisse Prozesse zu straffen,
zu beschleunigen
oder sogar über Bord zu werfen.
Wir können nicht mit Alltag
auf eine ausserordentliche Situation
reagieren.
Die Schweiz ist darauf ausgelegt,
dass man langfristig
wenige Veränderungen hat
und man das Wohlergehen
und den Reichtum der Leute
aufrechterhalten kann.
Sie ist nicht darauf ausgelegt,
innerhalb einiger Wochen
neue Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Die Schweiz ist konservativ
und schlecht
auf eine Pandemie vorbereitet.
Im April dieses Jahres
verdienen Grosskonzerne bereits
Milliarden mit Corona-Impfdosen.
Martin Bachmanns Serum ist indes
noch immer nicht auf dem Markt.
Er habe Mühe, Gelder
für weitere Studien aufzutreiben,
weil es bereits Impfstoffe gibt.
Ausserdem sei es technisch
nach wie vor schwierig,
den Wirkstoff
in grossen Mengen herzustellen.
Sollte man jetzt
nicht in anderen Bereichen forschen,
anstatt an einem Impfstoff,
der für wenige Leute sein wird?
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt.
Wir haben aber viele Dinge
rausgefunden,
die auch in der Grundlagenforschung
durchaus sehr interessant sind.
Wir haben z.B. rausgefunden,
dass gewisse Teile des Virus
besser geeignet sind,
um Antikörper zu generieren,
mit denen man auch die Mutationen
bekämpfen kann.
Das ist interessant für alle.
Es ist jetzt also mehr
Forschung für die Forschung?
Nicht nur, aber es war sicher
interessant für die Forschung.
Wir wollen den Impfstoff
unter die Leute bringen.
Und so arbeitet Martin Bachmann
weiterhin an seinem Impfstoff -
egal, welche Hürden
sich ihm in den Weg stellen.
Das gilt auch für Martin Bühler.
Der Krisenchef
war auf die Pandemie gut vorbereitet.
Er setzte neue Ideen um
und hat damit Erfolg.
Die Krise allerdings
ist noch nicht ausgestanden.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021